what do you've done on all the diet
school is there anything that you
subscribe to I stuck to Quito the
hardest peleas pretty easy
I like paleo - yeah I like paleo that's
kind of what I'm doing yeah a paleo
might be my favorite for longevity nuts
seeds vegetarian and I'm starting out
there work for me now I need my meat
yeah if you're working I don't think
about that all meat that you the
carnivore diet I think it's crazy
oh I I'm sorry do I look do I look like
an alligator yeah do I look like I just
consume meat I think it's retire I'm
sorry I'm I'm lying yeah no honey my
greens
nema grains so so the Bantu belt of
Africa like in in like Kenya and that
whole area - all the way down said I
forgot the Bantu about a lot of the
people other tribes like the Masai
people make it and get it twisted they
do live primarily on a carnivore diet
however they're also living with their
their their cows and their sheep not
having them drive there they're drinking
the blood and they're drinking the milk
with a suck in their - yes they drink
the milk they drink have everyone lined
that no without a suck on those tits you
have of the cow udders tits yeah under
the cows okay well how about this first
of all you doesn't squeeze it into your
mouth
apparently it's warm I don't want to
bust madad madad madad did in Wisconsin
when his young head but Dad dear
apparently madad madad madad sucked on
smothers you death shook off we tell ya
yeah he apparently he grabbed that other
and I do wanna do farmers do that a lot
oh I've always wanted a blade boy it's
the least they do I've always had I like
you I've always had a need to squeeze an
utter I wanna I sort of it is it's all
hug honors
ver so bad very quick utter story for
you I'm in Mexico this last time and I'm
chewing on this food and I'm like I
don't know man this meat tastes super
chewy it was utter meat yeah service
we're literally eating it and he said
other and I said it's it's seitan it's
not real meat and she goes I don't think
so and then we got the in he goes it's
the utter of the cattle your Canelo done
dude this is at a nice restored I was
like hey guys how about not cutting
corners and feeding me [ __ ] to honor
who the other top you'll see not to
prisoners or anybody no life it tastes
like rubber it sure did it tastes
exactly what you would think it tastes
like [ __ ] like chopped up rubber hey
amen
hi is this Goodyear tires dude speaking
of brothers my brother ate that rock
scientist barbecue and farted in the
greenroom
did he really and it I swear ting the
guy caring goes oh my god and Jay goes
who opened the grave oh my god you have
a fan or something kids without talking
it was like some dead person opened
their mouths and who just was writing
for you it was so work Sambi breath oh
dude and I looked at it's the only time
I got mad at Jellicoe it he's [ __ ]
me
what's wrong with you well we all have
to hang out here he goes I don't feel
like talking this comic in LA and you
know things aren't going great for me
goes you know I'm Anna I'm not like you
guys I can't kiss ass what excuse me
yeah yeah you know I just can't do I
can't kiss ass my god that's just the
wrong mindset - the wrong good god you
should kiss ass we at you and I are
talking about that I would when I got
into this business I might have sucked
your dick just for a small part and I
would have been happy to do it and this
idea that I don't compromise myself well
I get it I get not you know having sex
for money right I'm talking about do
whatever it takes that's because you
want it that bad
you're not touchable be a [ __ ]
untouchable clean cool Italian mafia
touch like [ __ ] the Train if you have
to to get yourself to the next like that
[ __ ] with your tongue and clean that
[ __ ] er well clean it well do the best
job you can and I swear to God with that
mindset you'll take it to the next yeah
but you're saying you're not saying arms
shouldn't kiss ass hopefully give me a
part you're saying because you want it
the dream so bad you're willing to do
what it takes [ __ ] right god damn
right there no excuses are there any
excuses are there at the end of the day
I mean I'm saying your whole family died
in the fire it's terrible but the but
but you don't stop moving no your
competition goes it's terrible but I'm I
got that pay bill - he's not here today
Oh me I'll go
yep that's all that's just how it is yep
I'm sorry that things that I you know it
doesn't matter if there are no excuses
it they and of course they're excuses
there aren't none and you if you look
back like then Madonna was eating trash
some [ __ ] like that
there's a story about and I've heard
this these are the stories I would
always read about people that really
made it and before they made it the kind
of hunger Quincy Jones where he came out
of he talks about like that you know
Madonna like like literally where they
were so hungry Billie Holiday Billie
Holiday holy [ __ ] I mean you're talking
about people who said they said what
drove you said hunger but real hunger
the fact that she was 13 years old her
grandmother in Harlem was gonna be
kicked out onto the street in the middle
of the winter and there was no net man
no and that's what she went to every bar
she went to every bar at 13 years old
cause she used to clean houses with her
Rambler her mother she went to every bar
and sang and at the end of the day she
picked up 37 dollars back then cuz her
boy said people were crying in their
beers and that's what how she saved her
grandmother for being on the street in
the middle of the winter in Harlem in
New York City New York City if you never
been in the winter there it is it'll
hurt your face it's so cold you can't be
out there you'll die so what happens
when we get to the point where we have
used everything even things that are
really serious and like like cuz I feel
like it's like the news and and the
media that may it's like oh we need this
star to seem more likable to sell books
next year next month it's like now let's
make them have an eating just you know
not make them or or or let's glorify it
even if it wasn't that bad oh you had
you struggled this or in high school you
actually liked another dude
right well you're gender-neutral yeah
yeah let's do that yeah fly the flag
hums like God dawg yeah yeah yeah that's
kind of gay are you trying to get some
fans in this area where it what it does
it's same thing with like these this me
to movement where someone would come out
like oh I had this issue where was it an
issue was consensual you're actually
down have done this as many of dudes
what you're doing is you're [ __ ] up
the movement because there's some actual
victims right and now when you do that
that you get the spotlight it takes away
from the actual victim yeah like
Jennifer Lawrence came out had some
story it was just like you know some guy
you know looked at me like while I was
changing a clothing or something I'm
just like that's somebody celebs photos
will jump on you know and that kind of
stuff we just want to relate to it yeah
they just want to relate and they don't
want to miss out on the opportunity to
seem correct it had their name in the
news you know but I think a lot of
America's starting to get hip to that
kind of stuff these days some of it yeah
and they're I think they're sick of it
yeah I mean I think you saw that with
like the Academy Awards it's like it was
like their lowest percentage watched
ever or the biggest drop you know
someone said to drop like 17% of viewers
yeah I have to work that I was bored oh
yeah House loved working the red carpet
for I was born yeah baby snatching
monkey after the baby was found dead is
this from my childhood because I uh this
is in Louisiana no India oh yeah like
Little India that's what they call
Louisiana really some parts and we saw
monkeys we didn't hunt monkeys what we
used to catch them when I was young cuz
they got out a monkey in India's eastern
state of Odisha what's this monkey doing
just stealing babies and killing them it
just grabbed a baby
Oh took it slammed it against the wall
and then they found it later
it's a terrible story but I mean it's
just crazy I feel sick okay they should
definitely kill that month so they're
looking for and of course they're gonna
they're trying to find it to kill it
they're looking for that monkey what
that looks like particular monk every
monkey yeah but also let's go ahead and
slap the parrots around there's no
monkey no monkey even if I lived in
India would be ever get close to my son
but I don't let strangers at the Grove
get close to my kid a little [ __ ]
wild hops it well this is the angriest
eye mechanic I've ever but these are
like people that live in a village you
know they can't control that they're not
like us yeah you couldn't if you could
not defend your child against monkeys if
you wanted to
Sharona would argue this to the end of
the earth you know no no Joe Rogan's
Road are you would straight up like
chimpanzees yeah yeah we're all [ __ ]
yeah that monkey yeah that's a monkey I
didn't slapping the piss out of that
thing that's a little spider monkey that
is a little spider monkey and look I'll
say this I was in was I mean I was in
Malaysia one time doing comedy nope just
just doing being a student I was a
student when I was younger and I was in
Malaysia and
I saw a monkey steal a bag of chips from
a black girl right [ __ ] racist
it is racist it's everything you know
it's everything it's stealing food from
people it's Star vez it's everything
starve is like artists
do you think you could take do you think
you just picture like a healthy black
woman you think you take a bag of chips
from her no and this monkey did it I
know but I'm saying it could do that
with the baby yeah was he on the sneak
though was there always gonna sneak over
there and both they're always on the
sneak and they're a sign just say do not
touch the monkeys do not feed the
monkeys don't tell keys don't like us
and that's why we didn't come from
monkeys is one of if they're doing this
kind of [ __ ] dude this isn't friendly
[ __ ] you know I know some people with
the steel chips - I've seen people steal
chips
yeah I've seen human steal chips we come
for monkey son okay I'll take that
that's a good point I don't think that
we do though I think that they don't
want us here and shits gonna get haywire
soon oh here you go again with the movie
plot so already quoted a mile now you
talkin about
Planet of the Apes like the lazy pool it
bothers me and then they have the big
wave pool which was my favorite it gets
too crowded people get [ __ ] up I find
it dangerous yeah yeah well wave pool
basically just who's gonna get rescued
from your family for real somebody
always gets rescues your drunk uncle he
thinks he can swim they know the [ __ ]
has been to the beach you have people
from you know wherever in Colorado we
call it south shore there's a big wave
pool super dangerous we're not using big
s ways we're on the beach so we know how
to react to those things yeah so dudes
we're getting [ __ ] yeah crying in
Colorado it's a hate crime cost yeah
there's a strong wave dogging her son
unbelievable one second cus a bunch of
caen Cassie's out there wave pool that
that lazy river whoever came with that
is a special [ __ ] demon dude somebody
[ __ ] him one when I was out in the
Lafayette once I've done that before and
they didn't even clean it they're like
oh it'll you know the river adapts
that's what the lady said well it ain't
a river it's off see man-made no the
river
this is the Colorado River Los Angeles
River is but it's not really a river yes
it is it's not a real one like the
Mississippi it pays taxes ro it's a real
River no Ben